it's my pleasure to welcome you to a
hundred Palestine studies events last
summer when the center was still a gleam
in our eyes I had the occasion to call
Dan Walsh our speaker today because he
had a well-known large collection of
Palestinian posters and his first
reaction and his consistent reaction has
been that his posters were our posters
that they what was available to me when
he put up he curated and gathered
together was something that was
completely available for the use of the
center as a group and in fact his poster
collection which is called the Palestine
poster project archives technically you
can find as one of the original dings on
the center website one of this original
resources that we put up and part of
what we hope is a growing list of
scholarly resources for
work on Palestine the Palestinians but
it's very distinctive source a great
distinctive archive and that's what he's
come to talk to us about today he is a
graduate student at Georgetown
University in the center for the study
of contemporary Arab society and he's
also an affiliate of the Center for
Palestine studies at Columbia he came
today with hard copy in addition to all
this wire technology came with a gift to
the University specifically to the
library our middle east librarian co
capture motto has the actual hard copies
here this nice gift of a selection of
interesting important posters maybe the
beginning of something big in terms of
the hard copies being available a
consultation at the library he also
today in conjunction with the center has
put up an archive 100 what he calls
iconic posters this is under the title
of one archive one narrative this went
up and you can heal up on the front page
the homepage of the center website you
will see the link to this slideshow of
very remarkably beautiful posters
interesting posters with some narration
is own archive the mother are concerns
because in excess of 4,000 posters at
this point and this continues to grow
every day we get notifications of new
acquisitions and new growth his talk
today is cobbled together from a number
of digital sources we have a slight
technical glitch but I think you say you
have two out of three of the sourcing
yet I think we become and the talk is
entitled a pixel is worth a thousand
words first verbs that watch okay thank
you thank you thank you having me here
and I have to begin with some some
acknowledgments I i have to thank the
memory of dr. it would say who gave me
my first grant for this work talking
about 25 years ago through the American
Palestine Education Foundation 3,500 not
to take a small collection of posters
Palestine poses that I had collected as
a Peace Corps volunteer in Morocco
between 1974 in 1976 and the grant was
for a slide projector and some trays and
some photography to make the slides and
then I began this whole journey by going
around to schools and social activist
groups in Washington DC and telling the
story of Palestine through the posters
of Palestine
and I also want to thank my my academic
advisor at Joyce not dr. Michelle Davis
who was here a couple of weeks ago
speaking who have been very supportive
of this and given me some leniency and
encouraged me to look at the post is
less as I had done for the last 25 years
running my design company liberation
graphics looking at them aesthetically
and politically and Georgetown I've
learned how to look at them
anthropologically and ethnographic which
is a much deeper and much more
interesting way to look at art and
basically I'm my I'm going to speak
they're going to move back and forth
between two websites this one which is
the actual exhibit of one archive one
narrative I'm going to explain that in a
minute what the title means and my
website for the Palestine post the
project Parker so there are two parts
might be such one is the Palestine
poster project archive which is the
website has almost 4,000 posters and my
new curriculum which is a link at that
website and okay so I've okay and I also
wanted to thank artisans and studio who
put this together for me as an studio
Ramona and I want to thank dr. Eric
saquen who's a professor of modern
Hebrew and contemporary Israeli history
at the University of Maryland who has
encouraged me to incorporate the posters
of Zionism into the Palestine poster
project and I'm going to explain why
that's really good idea
how it works and he's also handles most
of the Hebrew translations at
contextualization of Zionists posters
roughly 1898 to the present plumbing so
I've covered the three we're going to
look at the new curriculum we're going
to look at one archive one narrative and
the Palestine poster project archive and
um the main problem i'm trying to
address of my thesis this is the only
reading i'm going to do here is that
there's an absent of an integrated
authentic curriculum of the early
history of palestine in American high
school textbooks I eat if you go into as
I did I did a survey of high schools in
Washington DC Montgomery County Maryland
and fairfax virginia at the honors level
at the international baccalaureate level
and all high school textbooks that we
use all the curriculum ola syllabi and
every one of these examples and every
one of these places i don't know why
that happens there it is in every one of
those schools when you go in to find out
how the history of the palestinian
Zionist conflict is being taught you
find that without exception every single
American 11 every single high school
textbook
looked at in Montgomery County and
Maryland in Fairfax County Maryland are
two of the top six counties in terms of
income the number of PhDs the number of
congressmen and Senators Supreme Court
justices income i think the average
income in both places is over 150
thousand dollars and so they can buy any
textbook they want and they can have an
International Baccalaureate program of
whatever level of prestige they want in
every single one of them they start the
discussion of the Palestinians I'm is
conflict on anybody want to take a guess
11 that that starts what the date is for
the discussion of the Palestinian 1948
everything happened in 1948 everything
happened but motivated specifically made
15 1948 as the leading textbook in
Montgomery County says to sum up and
introduce the chapter on the Palestinian
often called the arab-israeli conflict
the lead sentence goes in 1948 israel
declared its independence and the Arab
countries invaded that's the that's the
context for the discussion of the
Palestinians is confident time before
that almost doesn't exist and so what I
found was that American high school
students were and teachers are really
bogged down in the sense that the
teachers don't know what to teach they
only have the curriculum the efficient
person stuff that they have to teach you
go into the classrooms probably
everybody maybe remembers this the
discussion around Palestine Israel's
very cramped and so that's an
uncomfortable place not comfort zone by
any means and so I tried to I tried to
change that and I tried to look at three
things I tried to address three well
either I want to talk about where the
study of Palestine
is in America the American high school
and Issler who is the Guru of American
curriculum said in a book he wrote in
1994 that there were four kinds of
curriculum there's the formal and/or
official which is what the state puts
out as a as a model that teachers have
to follow there's the informal which is
what the teachers do with formal
curriculum there's the hidden curriculum
which is stuff that gets taught that's
not part of me the formal informal can
be part of a question a student asks or
something that gets added into the
curriculum so we all learn about
something that's not good and then
there's the null the null curriculum
that which is specifically not taught
now you can make the argument that the
early history of Zionism and the origins
of the Palestinian science confident are
not part of the null curriculum because
nobody's deliberately not teaching in
fact there's one textbook in the Fairfax
library that can be used where you
actually can read about Dreyfus and the
rise of European nationalism and the
rise of anti-semitism and the origins of
German anti-semitism and the Dreyfus
Affair the whole struggle over
assimilation and the emergence of Zion
you can do that but it's 472 pages
earlier in a chat
under European nationalism it's nowhere
near the chapters having to do with the
Palestinians I'm as confident so what
I've tried to do with my with my own my
new curriculum is to create a resource
that teachers and students and
increasingly the general public could
use in order to look at the early years
of the palestinian zionist conference
specifically august twenty-first 1897 up
to make 14 1948 you'll find some
references broken up fractured nuance
perhaps I think anemic in some of the
textbooks there is nothing that that
actually follows an arc from Theodore
Herzl and the bath of the first
scientist congress in basel in 1897
where's I anism actually launched itself
onto the world stage on up to today so
that's the that's the the object of my
new curriculum is to make it possible
for an American high school student who
doesn't come from any ethnic or
political background and who wants to
learn about the issue and its
authenticity that he or she can go to a
place and learn about it in toto the
second thing was that I felt that
something was needed to encourage that
kind of analysis and the poster I find
among the printed materials on the issue
that you know this book's this film's is
there's a essays and lectures and
there's a whole series of printed
materials and published materials on the
on the Palestinians honest conflict but
I felt
there was nothing that actually engaged
the students and what the National
Council in social sciences calls civic
competence because there is the actual
if you go to attend any of these
teachers conference especially
curriculum development progressive the
progressive curriculum development
conferences the object of a progressive
curriculum is not to teach us you know
the minutiae of this battle with that
person or you know if to get us to spell
the name of some individual correctly
it's actually Civic competence Civic
competence busy is the civic competence
the ability of the students to either
while they're in the class or at home or
after they graduate to actually carry on
a discourse about the subjects they
discussed in class and there's not a
single curriculum or syllabi or outline
or anything that I looked at in any of
the schools that i visited and presented
at that actually teaches or gears its
work towards civic competence students
are still pretty much be photos and the
subject of Palestinian nationalism and
political Zionism continues to to to be
almost all limits to be something that
people even want to get through quickly
they sense that they have very many
questions but it's not something that
teachers feel particularly competent
about and so that the curriculum and
that whole arena is very stale and has a
real
love that for I would say 40 years it
has certainly hasn't been revitalized in
40 years so the question was how do how
do we how do we move how do we how do we
change things so i use the poster and
when I go into the classrooms the first
thing i do is i have a video I don't
have a PowerPoint presentation but i
can't get bored here today but I have a
PowerPoint presentation I send in
advance plus the website the students
and the teachers are allowed to look at
it and encouraged to look at it and
basically what happens when I go into
the classroom is I put up the post as I
asked a simple question trying to change
the dynamic I stay to the students what
do you see in this poster and what
happens with that is the teacher and the
me the resource I'm generally called the
resource person on the outside resources
we stand aside and we just listen and a
really interesting thing happens the
students really take control of the
question and it's a new way to teach the
history of the Palestinians iced coffee
basically by having the teachers listen
and answer questions because they go
through and they say what do you see in
that post as a whole series of things
students some of the questions are
ridiculous and some of the things that
don't make sense but in terms of what's
called practical anthropology the
students are asking questions and they
begin to talk and argue and debate the
issues among themselves and by the time
a half an hour into the classroom we've
gone through maybe six or eight posters
and generally I learned something in the
process and that changes the dynamic
because that's actually perfect we
actually then take the classroom of
American high school students and
probably for the first time in their
lives they're talking about Palestinian
national isn't talking about a
pan-arabism the tournament maybe
semitism actually questioning asking
questions about Zionism and theodor
herzl so it changes the dynamic
because people are actually practicing
for civic competence so I think that
that's one of the things that the
Palestine poster does uniquely it does
it better or differently or maybe
complete contravention to books and
lesson plans and literature and lectures
it actually allows for the origination
of the discourse to be altered and to
say rather than the teacher to be
lecturing actually teachers then become
resource people and answering questions
because what the question is do they
allow the students to establish their
own comfort zone so by the time I come
back to or maybe four weeks later to do
a follow-up is a completely different
there's a completely different dynamic
going on in the quest to a teacher to a
single one in all the districts Maryland
the district mo say that the the
curriculum as I put forward has been is
unique and completely different from any
other they've used on the code on the
pepper to teach what they call the
Middle East or the arab-israeli conflict
however that that's cool defines the
issue by altering the the locus of
discussion and allowing the students
actually drive the discussion you get a
completely different completely
different dynamic
and I'm going to go along in every ten
minutes or so when I feel I've gotten to
the end of the section I'm going to
encourage people to ask questions as we
go along rather than to save it to the
end because it might be some people who
can't stay or whatever so and you may
not remember them so if you have
questions feel free to shout out raise
your hand or whatever I'd like to
address them in the context of the of
the second so are there any questions
about microp might just my my thesis and
why I put it together the way I did a
question can you tolerate there being no
like you wanted for that or not we try
that and the posters will come up better
if you need to be able to see something
not only that I just want to be able to
move back and forth between okay so okay
so it actually goes little bit so very
briefly about this about this website
it's called one archive one narrative
because what I found out was that when I
started to put together the new
curriculum as 12 lesson plans and I had
roughly four or five posters for
pearlescent play well as I went around
to the different schools the teachers
kept saying well are there more posts as
other additional posted do you have post
is on the Balfour Declaration you have
posters on theatre Herzl you have these
other posts because there were elements
within their curriculum that they had to
teach for reasons I don't underst
and every single American School
District I visited for all I know every
single American School District in the
country teaches the Balfour Declaration
I don't know why it's not really a
declaration it was a letter passed from
a king to a cabinet member privately and
it wasn't even announced in Palestine
where I was afraid would cause riots so
there's nothing declarative about the
Balfour Declaration but it's it's part
of the formal curriculum in all the
districts and teachers have to teach
about the Balfour Declaration and I mean
it's not a really important part of
understanding you know the Palestinians
items coming but it's in there and we
can do about so teachers started to ask
for more posters and so what I did is I
put together a website where i could put
the other posters that i had really want
well oh he can't he went to the to the
dark ok so you all you want in the
directorship so um so woman what I
learned was that there were great many
posters and as the teachers asked for
them they the Palestine post the project
archive part of this which will go to
which is right here I think I can just
click on this that makes it happening ok
this is the website there are almost
4000 posters in there that actually grew
and just I started putting up posters
and hundreds of happy I should tell you
that when I was a peace mission said
this in the earlier on when I was a
Peace Corps volunteer Morocco 74 276 I
was stationed in a what was then a
little small suburb outside of marrakech
it's now part of Marrakech proper and I
was teaching in Arabic eight hours a day
and I had been plunked on it I didn't
have any background in Arabic and so the
peace book assigned be a tutor in the
morning you came to my house before I
went to school and a tutor at night that
I was studying to 24 hours an hour of a
good day for two years and it was
generally just one day ahead of my
students in terms of by using the
terminology for the curriculum to teach
the classes and you know it was a lot of
work it wasn't something I was supposed
to study French that was what the Peace
Corps I'd said I was going to be
studying here I was studying slanted a
note back on
and after about six months I was not
burned out but it was was a tedious
thing my the two to one of the 22 said
to me you know what you should have some
fun with this take a dictionary go on
you going to Casablanca next week
translate some posters so when I get on
the buses you know stop to check the oil
that people on and off and I was a break
I'm get up and I walk on and I would
translate the posters or try to
translate the puzzle generally the
Moroccans who came up around me who were
illiterate in Arabic okay where is they
wanted me to tell them what the posters
set and so this very interesting dynamic
developed I got taken home to lots of
really interesting meals and generally
somebody would step forward helped me
out and we translate a poster and this
went on for some time one day I
translated a posted it said Palestine
and I didn't know it said Palestine
because my limited Arabic was trial
iterable and this had four consonants
and what did that mean and then and it
was a Palestine poster and it was in
Rabat and it was in front of the palace
the PLO mission which I didn't know
anything about either a guy came out saw
me struggling with the translation said
you want to copy the poster I hadn't
even thought this poster which was glued
to the favor actually was piece of pain
somewhere in starting life is it and I
get taken into a room given a couple of
hundred posters and that's how that
started and I now have the largest
archives in the world and it's roughly
4,000 post was this roughly 4,000 yeah
but only 2,000 of the posters that I
have in my basement are online because
the other two thousand that are
happening here are things that are
either that have been sent to me on the
internet or their actual posters that
have taken place now people you know
that the Palestine poster husband in the
Palestine poster that the Palestinian
poster the poster of Palestine starting
around 1898 sorry about 1890 with French
and Italian travel companies of
precursors of wagon meats & Associates a
national du chemin de fer the tourism
companies of taking religious travelers
to Palestine to visit the holy sites so
the earliest Palestine poster which is
up here i'll get to in a minute eighty
ninety eight comes from tourism in 1897
the Zionists had the first for science
congress they have informed the baza
program one step of which was organized
world world support for Zionism and to
use all means of promotion to reach
people so they did but design is
published books in the movies
they adopted posters so that you can't
say that the European tourism industry
was originated the genre the palette the
Zionist in nineteen seven in 1997 1897
recognized that they had to publicize
their issue at about 1910 they started
producing posters in serious numbers and
they produce Palestine posters from from
1897 on at the 1948 almost every poster
published by a Zionist publisher what
said Palestine visit Alice tyne
investment Palestine travel to Palestine
have a great alacrity so the the
Palestine genre was given a great shot
in the arm by early Zionism made 14 1948
the Palestine poster as we know it will
see it in the show cease to exist
because scientists pounds by no longer
existed historical palestine ceased to
exist and israel came into existence and
i'll show you some posters in a few
minutes where the same printer within a
month of I've changed the poster from
visit Palestine to visit Israel and so
did the Palestine poster sort of went
dormant from about 18 98-94 so 1898 we'd
say it was born flourishes and we'll see
some great posters done by zionist post
poster artist and that 50-year period
1948 with the war of independence
there's a few palestine post is
published by some mostly egypt from arab
country
but it doesn't exist really as an
important sharma until after the battle
of al karama in march of 1968 when the
Palestinians and Israelis went at each
other at the babble of Karama everybody
claimed victory but one of the main
outcomes of the battle of the Kurama was
that palestinians began to take
seriously the idea of international
solidarity information production and
dissemination and one of one of the
vehicles that they adopted was the
poster and maybe I should go too funny i
have a completely different page you and
so that i'm going to go to fat that i'll
go down to fat that will just get a date
him
another 400 posters in this young now
okay okay so here we have here we have a
special collection of the posters of
feta which you can see in the early days
there were mostly black and white many
of them don't have logos they're not
sign and they're basically works done on
the run for all together but artists
came artists came out of the woodwork
Palestinian Arab Muslim and
international artists came out of the
woodwork and started to contribute
artwork and fact that took took takes
took the poster very seriously and used
it for all kinds of things affect the
only book written on the Palestinian
publish poster Palestinian posted
moisture figure had one is actually a
doctoral dissertation on this early
period when the Palestinians were just
beginning to comprehend the use of the
poster has a way to generate solidarity
and also as a way to tell a story and to
and to counter even internal Palestinian
this Palestinians talking to one another
many of these early posts are done only
in Arabic so you know like this one here
never which is in the library of
congress
doesn't have a logo it just down here
this who knows much I didn't post in yet
in Arabic and that this poster the
original is in both the library Congress
permanent collection which I've tried to
get them to find they can't find a
poster so that we can shoot a better
JPEG of it it's also in one of the
earliest important books about about
poster art contemporary cosas called
prop mark by Gary anchor so I'm going to
go back to the Special Collections a
scroll down yet and come back to the
soap stay on that
so I'm going to scroll down just so you
can see because this page has everything
on one page scroll that just you can see
how like today you know like
and today the PLO is gone 286 using
Photoshop and you know cutting edge of
web-based graphics and all kinds of
slick
advertising tools and resources and so
so in nineteen nineteen sixty-eight done
this in the art it's important to
establish a roughly eighteen ninety the
European tourism creates the genre the
first Palestine posters Zionism in 1997
with first Congress adopts the poster as
a serious reason ilysm for 50 years
creates Palestine posters that that ends
in 1948 is a hiatus 1968 battle of el
kerim the the PLO adopts the poster as a
serious communications resource and
shortly after almost like within a year
international or the international art
community gets involved in that which
explains the four Wellsprings do all of
these posters the four thousand a year
the four thousand are still in my
basement into thousands that are being
created all around the world on
Palestine right now they all come from
for Wellsprings Israeli in Zionist
artists and agencies Palestinian
nationalist artists and agencies is
Muslim and Arab artists and agencies and
international artists and agencies so
you can put all the posters that are
done here in one of those four
categories and the reason why I didn't I
chose not to call this the Palestinian
post the project carcasses
many of the posts have not done by
palisades and project so if the
palestinian national is java Wellsprings
only one there's only one of four and
it's not even the largest not yet a so
so if it some of the concern was that by
putting these two archive by putting
these archives together I was basically
equating them or you know there's the
whole issue of normalization now within
within the Palestinian national
discourse and I'm not suggesting that
these posters are equal or that they're
all the same or or that some are better
than the others or whatever what I'm
saying is that for an American high
school student to try to understand the
origins of the Palestinian science
conflict if you get a grasp on it and to
be civically competent to be able to
discuss with teachers and their
neighbors and other people the arc of
history they have to basically have
access to the same history that
Palestinians and Israelis do they have
to be able to argue the issue the same
way Palestinian nationalist and
political Zionism and I found that the
only way to do that was to present all
the posters the Zionists provided some
of the early
posters which gives us really a a window
into Zionist psychology and early
Zionists history and then starting in
1968 Palestinians play an increasingly
important role in flushing out the
details of that history so are there any
questions at this point could you show
us in the back with Palestine in 1897
yes well 1898 I mean I did and if I can
figure out Miriam showed me how to do
this
so we're going to love that i'm going to
write him up
who is the oldest the earliest poster in
the and the archives to date there are
two versions this one here
this is published by
and this is an incident slideshow as
well this is published by Paris Lyon
Mediterranean tour lines which is which
is a precursor of the modern French SNCF
which is the French national rail
service and what you could do when you
do with this PLM company was doing they
was saying get on train in Paris and
you'll go to Leon and while saying
you'll get on a boat will take you to
Palestine you can visit the whole twist
so this is the oldest one there's
another very tight territory sorry it's
not the entire territory yes / guess
from men oh did you ask your hands from
that oh yes I taught us to see this the
oldest I don't ok well there's a special
collection here called maps so
comprehensible let's go to that
so there's a there's a map for from 1710
and this one here Mars Mediterranean
Mars is a I think it's from 1580 and
dates in there somewhere but there's a
hole there is it actually a map website
of Palestine map website that has all
kinds of maps this is just the ones that
have been poster eyes so did I answer
your question could you ask it again
when we give me another chart to show us
a map Palestine exist no no I
yeah I don't okay so so it is 109 maps
at this website most of them are in
posted war and they were their product
with modern lithography so it's a
territory or was there another question
that somebody else has continued and
you know buddy there's a host is a whole
special collection than here on United
Nations posters okay so any other
questions and okay so so as it so I'm
going to shift now from the from the
actually put back the necklace I can
just wrap that up into it okay so what
you do it in this it's a hundred posters
it has two web links 11 takes you to the
to the website I know it takes you to
the scent of Palestine studies website
and up there you click on the number
that will take it to that posters page
in the website so if you want more
detailed information or any wiki links
or if it's part of if that artist has a
special collection or if it's part you
can get to even get a more complete data
for that post by clicking on that and
you can click on this button right here
to go to go to the next poster and you
click on the return arrow to go back and
this is what's on the website as of
today this is the website
columbia center pronouncements that it's
actually being they do great emphasis
risotto sentences there's a hundred post
is it's helpfully the first many
exhibits online exhibits i hope to
actually have one for every special
collection has been a lot of interest in
having the post is used as screen savers
and classrooms and as exhibits so we're
going to try to format the entire the
entire four thousand posters in however
many and winds up into discrete and
focus slideshows okay all of these
posters are available to students to
download journalists wherever there's no
copyrights involved in any of these to
make use of the JPEGs and for most of
them if you click on a few let's click
on this one here you go here you can go
almost for all the artists to have them
I've clicked directly to the artists
special collection click on the post you
can actually write you want went this
you know the artist to business and if
an artist is alive and has a website
that is an email and is sent it to me I
included it so you as the student of the
journalists of the research you can go
reach the artist directly there's no no
you know the right to me to get the
artists to get the artists information
if it's available now I'm going to go
okay so now we're going to stay here and
just go through a couple of the Special
Collections there are four hundred and
forty-four of the massive today a
special collection I took a library
science of course two semesters ago
special collection can be anything and
have one one thing in it or can have
thousands of things and I've organized
these as special collections of artists
publishers themes and large publishers
and themes and sometimes events and this
will so be broken out so that instead of
404 before going through you'll be able
to say I want to know about artists and
all the artists will be listed in it
publishers and the things we program so
they'll only be five special collection
categories with far fewer far fewer
entries in them and
change in the way the Palestine poster
exists today as opposed to the way it
existed coming into being is that from
19 from 18 will say eighteen ninety
eight to nineteen forty eight early
Zionism used a poster really really
effectively and I had created what I
considered to be one of the great unsung
political postage genres of the of the
20th century and here are just well I
mean this is a this is the wellspring
but the early- hired some of the most
talented people many artists came out
and did works in solitaire what Zionism
the bezalel school and in Jerusalem had
it was one of the was one of the first
places to teach contemporary poster
design and typography and the principles
of design in the Middle East this is
this here is a this is a work but I call
him unidentified artist number two
because he did for real p of xi is for
really important works but i can't find
a name because it wasn't considered a
port
time for them to this artist to sign his
or her work but let's just stay here for
a second one of the things that Zion
early Zionism did with the post it was I
had four objectives it was to promote
tourism to Palestine to promote a Leo
immigration to Palestine to promote
investment and to promote industry so
the Zionist cat-boy organized
exhibitions the United States and all
over Europe every year and you could was
like a mini world's fair you could go to
this exhibition some of them cost a few
francs or Deutsche marks to get in and
they would have tents set up or many
factories or they have cuisine from the
area have people who have made the trip
to Palestine to talk to people to
recruit new immigrants and there's a
whole series of Palestine exhibitions
where you could go and you go by
handicrafts you can do all kinds of you
could get us that you could supposedly
get a sense of what it was like to
emigrate to to Palestine through these
exhibitions and this is an example of
for one is promoting amazing tour
promoting industry
alia and the other one is an
international nearest Fed was actually
in counseling so so the Zionist the
early Zionists
I want to go back to the early sign
basically create basically created a
genre de for reasons I don't really
understand is not is not appreciate its
not promoted by either the Israeli
government for or any of any major
American academies or institution
seriously here's the website of the
central Zionist archives in in Jerusalem
it's a little clunky it's not all that
informative but it is only has 125
posters on it but you can you have to
click through like four or five
different buttons to get to anything
many of them don't have translations
some of them do and you can just get a
sense of the town that was mobilized to
create this early Jean of this John of
early Palestine POSIX and I'm going to
go back and say why see if I can
that you know the front of the 1897 to
1948 for scientists one of the greatest
things to be able to do is to say i am a
palestinian the rubric palace
palestinian was adopted by zionist to
identify those people who had gone to
palestine medallion committed themselves
designs and david ben-gurion used to say
that he stay i'm a palestinian and he
would explain that he would come to the
United States and say I'm a Palestinian
as a way of sort of embarrassing Jewish
Americans who hadn't made alia that to
be to be authentically Jewish and to be
involved in the Jewish Renaissance one
had to make Polly and so what I say my
thesis I have a five-point definition up
here in this section is that a Palestine
poster is above all else or put any
poster from anywhere with for any
language on any reason that has the word
Palestine it in any language so the
early Zionists posters almost all had
word Palestine and the more printed in
Palestine walk whatever slope that
established genre
and and by by incorporating the poster
art of early Zionism Americans and
American students and I'm specifically
focusing on Esther students trying to
grasp the issue I'm not focusing on hot
galleries and collectors enough people
who are also welcome till the visit the
site with my site has a very specific
demographic they can they can see the
posters that were actually used to teach
the principles of Zionism to proto
scientists and by zionist artists and
published by zionist publishers and so
this was and so the quality of that
narrative is is unsullied island there's
no interpretation really involved on my
part I can just present the material and
say here's house I anism show the world
or swords principles or and consider its
objectives through its poster art
starting in 1898 and I'm going to try to
find for you here the perhaps the most
well-known depending upon
certainly the most talked about
Palestine posted on the last five or six
years well it's published but it's
designed by this artist so I'll get to
it through this but Franz crafts was
considered was considered am just
considered the ominously of Zionist
postcard
and visit Palestine and there is an
entire there's an entire sub-genre
within this that all has that all have
the same time and they pretty well
represent the tourism the tourism rubric
of the design exposes showing the early
one showed you know build industries and
invest this one here promotes mostly
religious but for purposes if you read
any documentation purposes of generating
foreign currency tourism they were happy
to have tourism tourists from anywhere
and this poster as an interesting
history it was reprinted it was
originally printed 1935 by the Jewish
Agency for tourism and Jewish Agency for
tourism in Palestine it says that on the
poster but in 1995 in the wake of the
Oslo Accords and you know that David
took Taco Bell who's the was the Dean of
America of sorry of Israeli graphic
design one
the Herzl prize that's re the Israel
prize in 2005 and he's considered
leading graphic designer of Israel he
reprinted this posted because he crosses
logo over here and he reprinted it
exactly as it was and you be issued it
and he was surprised we've had
interesting conversations I interviewed
who has during in his house in the old
city of junk and when he reissued he
reissued it as a way of honoring crowds
and of a sort of celebrating the Oslo
Accords and the emergent piece at the
environment was that he had no idea that
Palestinians we're going to see this
poster and immediately appropriated and
basically adopted as their own because
for the Palestinians the this poster
here basically kiss the legs out from
under a series of Zionist mitts that you
know there was never a place called
Palestine or whenever people living in
Palace
I was a barren desert so this poster is
at last count being published by at
least 12 underground Palestinian
publishers including in Gaza and it
sells like crazy and sold out the david
packard we did the original press run
sold it through the Israel Museum where
it was a blockbuster it sold like crazy
hardly any tourists they said that for
the months that it was available hardly
anybody left the Israel Museum without
buying a copy and so there's a deep
irony in here in that post is published
by Zionism in 1935 carried a very
different message and we'll received
very differently than they were when
they were probably published in 1995 and
so this poster has become sort of like
a.m. it was a is a product of early
Zionism but has become a sort of the
standard in Palestinian refugee camps
and Palestinian homes because
Palestinians in embodies the
the the country it challenges central's
I some central Zionist claims to the
barrenness of the land and the fact that
the number was passed and there are
several dif offroad what I picture of
this book the what not even this book
because education the way I could
petition Vicky is a are you saying
desert ification meaning us as in there
being a desert on the area beyond the
building trailer cypress trees there was
a cypress tree right here is gardens as
much god I wouldn't be these are the
trees in Arabic cypress trees in the
garden in cypress trees years ago oil is
now counted them
so what your point was that was your
point that this poster points out that
Palestine was a desert when they come
from well then let's look that you raise
a good point let's look at a couple of
the other on posters from that period
that do the same thing that basically
touch on the same subject here's a
poster and done Maya Sieber Bond who was
also wanted to great early posts a
couple Palestine talked about the Jewish
Agency for tourism in Palestine and
there you see a very different you see a
very different Palestine from the one
that's spoken about you know as a desert
and land for people people this is this
is not the Palestine that most
scientists were saying existed when they
tried to recruit people and say they and
the land is emptiness
they're coming and bring it to life this
is a very lush and burned and populated
place okay all right okay so you're not
having to go get that one no one works
for you too okay I'm not sure that
anyone post that can deal with oil an
analogy or old or all the this by the
way copies of all of these are do you
want to see the originals the Library of
Congress has all of these as well as
online so here's another one visit
Palestine and what I'm basically what
I'm saying is that in terms of the class
discussion taking place because saying
visit Palestine is what did they see
that they wear Zionist promoting in
their posters a vision of Palestine or
an image of Palestine it was consistent
it would say what they were within their
publications or their lectures or or the
recruiting standards or what the posters
which were meant for tourism showing
completely
may who we want to go to the places in
there and you're I understand why they
did it in fact there are accounts I'm
going to put them online you can read
the accounts of the discussions that
went into choosing the iconography and
the problems that my grades so again
it's an example of a poster done in the
1920s and 30s that runs counter to the
narrative of either what Zionism had to
say about say today or what it said it
was saying in the 20s and 30s that make
sense
right okay what was it like the grave
encounters I think there are hungry go
yeah biblically yeah let's go let's take
your question while I see the phone they
have a motive to say but that is life
that its work on Saturdays let go to
stop there but Sturridge his act as a
bit what's called biblical first time
okay well here's another one with no
people it's actually another poster this
game we remixed over and over again it
was just used as opposed to for I think
his name is al sabah called the the
orange clockwork this was redone and i
have the poster in here again visit
palestine seen ancient beauty revived
disturb the double a dual purpose of
recruiting Zionists and working as a
tourism post come and see a place that
was being lowkey effective are
plus you have this hormone the work of
1935 circa 1930s this is when it began
now the clamp as the disappear we
brought development we deserve a week
well there is that well there is
elephant by you well there is that whole
argument there have been and that we can
certainly go and look into that but the
point is that the point I want to talk
about the post I want to talk about how
the post was you that specifically for
one thing is an example of the Haifa
1956 defense Thank You 58 pretend
anniversary of Israel's independence
celebrating you use the central feature
is a Palestinian dep keep dancing true
so so the XO as a way to promote tourism
Israel was even design us at the time we
even willing to use agriculture promote
agriculture as a way to promote which is
which out which I'm not going to get
into with the rightness or wrongness of
that I'm only going to talk about
chattering up but interesting 10 frames
I do I appear a glove so Israel final
angular language the poster so 1958 10
years and they were very clear that we
made everybody happy we brought our
disparate people back home and that are
developed now they have us they have
less applauded after language we give
them school and entity and especially
interested this was not an important
this is why the the big like this and
our military Lucy at this time you have
I can go to my school without ever even
years old boy my father can't go to work
so we are celebrating the front row well
ok so the point the point I was trying
to make was that in the Indy scientists
over and this is engine there's
basically a period where the poster was
used to recruit new Zionist to promote
alia to promote tourism and to promote
investment after 1948 things change
still promoting tourism still promoting
all those all the other elements but
using a different using a different
palette and a different iconography one
that now include now includes
Palestinians in and
in a commercially positive way okay that
was the only point I was trying to me
but I appreciated to work and that you
put it all in one relative and I think
that gradually in two minutes I think I
told you to depart together I think no
matter what size the rather how they do
it it shows that understand okay thank
you thank you I'm going to move now to
helmet tuning we've talked about some
we're talking about some of the early
Zionists artists like Krauss and zebra
bond the one of the other genres that's
really interesting to look at is one of
the Wellsprings his Arab and Muslim
artists and so in the early days of
Zionism many artists check Bulgarian
French Italian Spanish king either
commercially go out of solidarity with
Zionism and produced posters in support
of Israel and Zionism promoting the four
goals and just mentioned tourism
investment alia and trade the same thing
happens the same thing happens after
1968 relative to Palestinian solidarity
were artists from around the world
begin to produce posters in solitary
Palestinian national something that
didn't something that didn't exist
before march 1968 and the battle of el
corral and part of the reason why that
is is probably worth mentioning is that
at the battle of al karama which was
supposed to be a cakewalk for the
Israelis Israelis had initially planned
to walk in spend four hours decapitating
the Palestinian political leadership in
the refugee camp of the same name next
to the town of Karama and so but it was
in Jordan because after the 1967 wore a
lot of the Palestinians the Palestinian
girls had led back over the border out
of the West Bank into Jordan and they
were congregating in in the refugee
camps licking their wounds because the
Israelis had trounce Syria Egypt Jordan
in the war and so the but the fact that
leadership kept doing raids into Israel
crossing over the border blowing up
bridges and stuff and the Israelis said
you know we don't need to tolerate this
we're going to send in a couple of
Italians and we're going to take care of
this problem so there's a couple of
really interesting accounts online
including at Wikipedia and so but the
problem was that the Israelis had a good
relationship with Jordan and they didn't
want they had to go in to join then they
had to do a lot of shooting and breaking
things up but they didn't want they
wanted the King king of st. understand
look this isn't about you we don't want
to hurt any Jordanians we just want to
go in kill the political leadership take
some prisoners and leave and so what
they did is they started to organize the
operation right out into public right
out in the open so that the Jordanians
who would you know had spiders as of
concede that the Israel
were massing militarily on the other
side that line ready to do something and
in fact the American ambassador at the
time was sent a message to Hussein is it
look this is what the realities are up
to they want you to stay back don't get
involved this is that this is a
israeli-palestinian thing you know this
is nothing to doing you so what happened
is a couple of officers into Jordanian
army they transmitted all that
information down to the Palestinian
leadership who couldn't go anywhere they
couldn't get back in they couldn't go
into Israel they couldn't be joined so
they decided to fight and so they sent
as many of the civilians away as they
could they began to gun up and when the
Israelis did come into the camps the
Palestinians were more or less ready for
them and it was a real shooter and
depending you know you can read the
accounts as a couple of really well done
and sort of unbiased accounts of the
casualties Palestinians cover 100 I but
these days was 67 soldiers dead a couple
of hundred wounded there was a couple of
Tanks to even lost the helicopter so at
the end of the day to pilot the town was
roaming the town was completely ruined
the camp was leveled it was a were to
actually two battles that took place the
whole area got shut up but end of the
day our pod and I wish she hadn't always
was still alive and in control of the
battlefield and the Israelis were going
back to cross the line so the Israelis
claim victory and so did the
Palestinians and coming on the way
coming in the wake of the enormous
defeat of the 1967 war all through the
Arab world the battle about Karami
reinvigorated our pride in Korean
palestinian a sense of palestinian
nationalism and almost in a sense of
utopia and in that moment in the moment
created by the by the outcome of the
valley dr on the palestinians organized
their first international political
political communications office called
unified information and all that I
posters will see on the bottom of almost
everyone done by fact that or any of the
dealer group decision ever letters mean
TAF at uno's motivator Faustina sorry ya
mean that idea and then under what
unified information and so coming out of
that you could say that the battle of al
karama whereas the whereas the first
zionist congress was the impetus and the
birthplace of the early Zionists
Palestine poster the outcome of the
battle of Karama in 1968 was the
Berkeley the birthplace of the
contemporary Palestinian nationalist
version of the Palestine poster and
there are many parallels and
similarities there's a lot of a lot of
differences between the two but the
thing that the thing that is common to
them is that they almost all have the
word Alice 9 printed on them they're all
talking about the same place and when
seeing together for making 97 up to the
present they tell what I considered to
be the only uncompromised history on the
contemporary Palestinian Palestinian
science conference the only source you
can go to you can't go to film you can't
go to books they put a poetry you can't
go to lick you can't go to any
the other any of the other media to get
the patcher together whereas the posters
tell the whole thing taking together
Zionist contribution as well as the
Palestinian contribution including
posters done by our Muslim artists and
the international artists did you have a
question I thought we might open it up
generally yes please I think maybe we
clearly have to come back it's only
4,000 but let's let's see how maybe XP
is out here in the crowd sure and I'll
just run out around the slideshow in the
background and all you know i'll leave
it open here if anybody wants me to go
to a specific poster or specific low
spring artist i can do that well spring
might say is your term for the source
for main sources of the posters yes it's
your own comes in but the wellspring
notion self is your turn yes yes but why
should run that slideshow of course I
think it's good idea let's have some
questions I mean these are incredible
resources to be used but we already
heard those comments that indicate how
complex they are and how contested
potentially any interpretation of the
more use of them might be you speak of
them as uncompromised but as soon as you
begin to
I'm not saying the posters themselves
might have like the you know visit
Palestine David dr. currently considers
that to be very compromised he considers
the contemporary Palestinian nationalist
use interpretation of that posted be
completely at odds with the original
intent but I'm saying that the so I'm
not saying individual posters are I'm
saying that the history the park of
history is not compromised it's all
there all the pup all the posters are
there while all the post is there and
also this section between 1998 and 1997
and 1948 is there which is not in
history books that so that one of the
contributions aside from the massive
collection and the largest collection is
that it doesn't cut out sections it's
president for Great Hall and sisters
that occurred in that air confessing to
and all the history that the post is
embody yet so that's what that history I
think already you were hearing from man
who left that that history might be
argued I don't want to hope it is argued
that's the whole point that's all
appointed this is to get people arguing
that right right good good comments 22
folks the history of the Sun will speak
review
on this one all all 1958 be accountable
as a huge demonstration
he should pick up just a little bit
protesting Israeli confiscation of plans
that is internally attack it would be
interesting to complement the range of
courses you have from Israel internally
from sources for the promise the
argument here for some people are I was
talking to have a sense of how the
Palestinians themselves made posters
about that painting
inside this room from 4867 the other
page which seems relevant the other
issues seem dragon is there are a lot of
posters again in that before the rise of
questioning the national struggle by
different our face our national
experience do you have access to can you
give me an Arab nationalist movement me
with initiative but no outside their
artwork for example the monster I do I
have a couple I have a couple of nossor
i posted and every puzzle but they don't
specifically relate palestine and this
is this is a website about Palestine hey
everyone's now I do have I mean I you
know like if a fine artist or publisher
say from you know the pan air movement
ok does a Palestine poster and I have a
Palestine poster establishing their
special collection then I can add
hostess let's show you know related
issues another word to do but if they
don't have a Palestine that's sort of
the entry price here is the publisher
Palestine groups I was posted with word
pass them once you've done that if
you've also you know an artist and like
David talked about if you done post has
done that and you've also done posters
promoting um you know bubblegum or
you know commercial products i can put
some of those in there as well but I
can't do it if you don't have a palace
numbers and I'd like very much to talk
to you about about the links you have
any ideas and be great so the Communist
Party would have posters of its own and
then they're obviously about Palestine
but they don't mention the word well I'm
gonna go tada probably so that sounds
like you then I think it sounds like a
you know if Palestinians are the
producers say in the Communist Party of
posters sort of daily posters or weekly
posters or whatever those two would
should be part of the collection
absolutely absolutely here's an example
just here's a special collection back in
mountain humble bunny and he worked on
between I mean believe all these works
here basically 76 286 so these were done
in the occupied territories during you
know under Israeli occupation and if you
look at them they renewed their very
different from the posters that done by
Palestinians outside of Palestine is no
good is very well this is the allusions
to guns but their counseling religious
and and religious and
quranic phrases the palate even the
palate because there was the infamous
Israeli regulation 101 I read about it
at the website where it was against the
law for Palestinians to replicate the
Palestinian national colors black red
white green it couldn't do so the artist
had to submerge that you know and fuzzy
greens and black of the outline so so
they were basically being as
naturalistic as they could be without
running without directly going to jail
so this is an example of how Palestinian
revolutionary posters look under
occupation and look and what came out of
it is very completely different
iconography and completely different
palette did you have a question these
blue-screen these your shirt is that
particular one you all again ain't there
let's open
I
so you know changed it constable for
imprisonment we got a couple about this
actually pretty billiton won the clinch
the clenched fist is a symbol for some
loot Palestinian the notion of debt
business and resistance his little
helmet like houses are feature of this
particular artists work the flower
represents a Greek blossoming
continuation of the determination sorry
blossom you get the outline of Palestine
here you can rub out and a Palestine
Gaza would be right here this is the
Sinai this one here continuity good
continuity as the title so you wouldn't
have way in this in this particular this
particular publisher and then routed
this particular artist that was arrested
a lot of times and I'm going to get
anything like you know revolution until
victory whatever this these works for
these words are their small pulses these
are about maybe 17 x 14 x 20 something
like that
and these were sold in sets never sold
by publisher coconut reship is now in a
business and they were meant they were
meant to be able to allow the artists to
deny that they were really tender that
they were anti-israeli or that they were
nationalistic maybe show us another one
from the same tradition by the same
artist yeah your wrongs in the same one
I don't have to go back and touch
come to know anything
the aryl heaven
okay let's try it okay so i hope this do
this one here which confused me for a
long time
this is the anniversary of a massacre
the anniversary of the massacre awamiya
which I haven't been able to find any
actual reference to that true yeah we
did find one okay we did find it okay so
here's here's a you know the iconography
to me is very disturbing her
psychological Patrese is the design
series of it's very experimental what's
called a coupla from movies and
basically represents me this is this
artist effort to commemorate the loss of
life at the Battle help they're walking
in which was one of the fire remember
this correct it was one of the villages
that would be populated by the Israelis
in 1948 more and many of these many of
those something like 400 villages and
many of them have commemorative posters
diria seen the one who is another one
and in fact dear we have seen actually
has its own special collection so the
lost the dr. Michelle Davis was here a
couple weeks ago talk about
period and the populated villages this
is actually literature is actual
literature associated with lost villages
for these both those memory books with
the surviving villages put posters and
maps and postcards and letters from the
village to prove that there was a
militant this poster is a sort of in
that tradition many of these you know
many of these posters are commemorative
every year these I should go to that let
me try that every year the Israeli
government and the PLO publish that
cynical Israel
is real independence day this is like a
really big collections 54 and grows well
I don't have them every year and getting
a 1949 this is the first this is the
first Israeli dependence day poster the
design by a guy named Ottawa issue was
what the one that is one of the great
early Zionists graphic designers every
year both the Israeli government and the
PLO published anniversary posters
celebrating just the fact of having
survived another year I mean that's the
subjects for Israeli and Palestinian
anniversary posts and they started out
only being done by the governments or in
the case of the Palestinian by the
pillow but now individual artists and
companies and el al airlines and the
Palestine Authority and Palestinian
schools everybody does everybody can and
one more people do produce anniversary
posts and self-published so it's not
it's no longer a genre that's you know
dominated by government produced posted
some of them are very some of these are
very very I think very educational this
an entire story and I have the have the
translation down below all the Hebrew
down below but it's basically a
compendium of Israeli and Zionist
symbology it tells a story about what
was important than the artists and to
the publisher of this person who was
this is the world zionist organization
because i saw his asian 1968 so and
these are very collectible Israeli coat
Israeli independent post independence
day posters are very hot ebay item I
don't think they were done in large
numbers and only a handful of people
thought to collect them and so there are
on a great many of
round this is something that some
something someone else wants to say most
what most recently this category I don't
know Israeli Independence post
well that was this one here
yes
since the birth of her 60-year 6 15
years so what you 2010 I don't have a
very good jpg of this this is something
I got it can go me hey I don't actually
have that person this is part of a
series and there were eight or ten posts
in this series that went put on the wall
tell the story I let's go let's go to
the let's go to the to the you know the
will go to them to this one you
and we'll look at some of the
Palestinian okay I'm going to actually
scroll down to 10 and right here this
here is considered this is this is a
poster that was done by a woman who was
now like a really famous as an okay many
of the artists that should go through
here fine artists who started out they
were 17 18 19 years old in 1972 and now
the like really famous like Klaus
bizarre in Paris and there's posters in
there by Peter Paul pash and people who
in their own worlds are accomplished and
famous maybe only were in it with in
Sweden only within England but a great
many a very many artists to as young
college students did works have gone on
to have spectacular careers and
interestingly her name is no longer
she's remarried and was
Elizabeth the carboy she did seven
posters for the general union of
Palestinian students back in early 1970s
she's now like Italy's leading
theatrical garment there's a name for
that people people make costumes a
period piece past which is like really
famous and she answered my emails nicely
this is a this is a post that celebrates
the seventh anniversary of the first on
action of which means the storm which is
the arm fact in the Armed element of
FATA so they actually was they were
celebrating the first military action
that fat that ever took which was
against this obscure which is up in this
little town called I am balling up in
the gallery against a water treatment
plant or why I actually water pumping
station and this poster one of the
things you can do with this phenomenal
resource called Drupal this is a this
poster she she took this from this image
she had a copy of this image which is by
nabeela Bob okay and basically branded a
cool color silk screen you know more
sophisticated version of the same poster
and you can oftentimes the same image
will go through 5 10 12 iterations from
artists around the world i'll show you
is anybody interested in seeing that
okay i'll go through an iteration for
come out blog that i'll show how
artist
because there's no sense there's no
notion of copyrights there's no notion
of copyrights within within the I mean a
handful of a handful of American artists
it's very little about copyright
infringement the notion of copyright
copyright infringement taking place in
any in this book although although if
you wanted to if you want to get Israeli
posta sword Zionists posted it's
oftentimes a challenge if you go into a
pact where you go to any of the
designers organizations in this country
even in Israel you ask for posters they
say you want to have posted it's
generally an interrogation of fathers
you get a lot of questions who's going
to see this poster where is going to go
why do you want this you got to get
vetted and stuff like that generally I
mean with no posters but I try because
by getting a copy of the poster I try to
get three copies of everything I put one
into Georgetown University Library one
in in the Palestine post of archives
collection and one I keep for places
like maybe Columbia for what third
parties because having saving the
original copies is really important if
you go into any Palestinian few
traveling around your suite or you're in
Chile or anywhere you go to a
Palestinian embassy or Palestinian
culture group and ask for posters walk
out with like they give you are you know
you want three copies they'll give you
500 comes to give everything that so it
is a very different notion even even
today of what the posters purposes and
whether or not the particular agency or
ideology that you are working with this
practicing what's called a broadcast
dissemination system or narrow kissed
dissemination
when works only narrowcast and
temporarily cast and the message is much
more controlled let me go to come out a
lot to hear and we'll look at how
iterations work across a graphic
okay so here's a poster that
so here's opposed to call revolution
until victory this was done circa
nineteen sixty-nine now if you click on
this one here called Palestine
palestine
you see it's the same imagery the exact
same imagery has been lifted off of this
post this is the earliest when this I
believe is 60 was the 69 but it's by
nabeel nada so what so it came from my
lawsuit oh because that's the that's the
logo up there okay so this was the first
one and then the post that we just saw
Camille come out with lived in this
country and worked in his country he
lifted it did another poster and then a
really famous or infamous depending upon
depending upon your work was the poster
publisher pro arts which was out of
small town of keeping a neighborhood
where Kent university is in Ohio these
guys started to reduce posters on all
kinds of issues and they lifted it this
is an American silkscreen poster a
commercial mass distributed they lifted
it and published it in opposed to the
day sold for five or ten years so that's
an example of how an icon moves across
cultures and across time and the post
that we spoke about earlier visit
Palestine has even been has even been
altered I don't it's not yet done but
here's here's that famous posted by
another
I back
Oh
like here if you couldn't see this here
that's the post that we looked at before
I could have brought it up and what you
know the visit Palestine and it had the
city and we talked about whether they
would treason and this artist is just
thinking and run a section of the
Israeli berry o / apartheid wall across
it to make his statement about the
ability to visit Palestine so it's an
example of how icons really never die
any questions let's see if there are any
more questions here's one I was going to
talk for a second about
water clusters the west bank and got
modern morning loves you and if you know
this is something you well it's
especially it's a special clutch asked
to be in there mean it's it's something
that something that exists I'll tell you
how I handle that is actually a guy in
Gaza who has taken it upon himself
there's a there's a youtube video about
this and he goes to every single funeral
and he hangs out at the poster shops
because you know one of the things that
one of the things that's happened is
that with digitization you can have
posters that were done in Brazil printed
in France for solidarity rally in Spain
so there's really no the computer used
to have have you used to have the artist
the printer to pay for everything in one
rule 21 town it's not that way anymore
I'm trying to get this to open to
Special Collections and I'll go to Mars
and Marta door closes and what what he
does is he goes to every single funeral
and he collects the and he collects the
posters of the martyrs 109 posts isn't
so now the first three posters in the
sky are Israel is the barcelona children
will be at the Martin was actually two
of the two separate versions of samples
so both Israelis and Palestinians you
know have Marta Marta composers and I
don't as a you know it's impossible for
me to ever able to get a poster that
maybe the family only printed ten copies
and it's just a picture of a guy who
when a gun or a casket or something so
it's very few niriel it's a couple it's
not if it's generally a pic store it's
entered a photographic genre it's not
really a graphic art it no artist was
involved and it just they just done in
two small numbers the family might print
four copies of something to give their
family so they do exist the contemporary
Hamas suicide bomber few niriel pub
Marta coast but there's also a longer
history of that and many of them off
works a lot and many of them were done
by famous artists and do tell the story
me know even you know I my my
four including a poster in martyrdom
special question is doesn't have the
word martyr in any language on the post
so we can't just say this company so
many kids I well I consider him a mark
the poster has the same monitor in order
for me to put it in any then this is a
small sample I probably have another 100
puzzles most of which were published by
organization that families okay I'm also
which comes from the 60s 70s and 80s
that is your question to get him going
to be someone this one right here
college is just above just an
marca de novo 576 this one right here
what did you what did you want to know
about them it is curiel you're curious
no no it's just
issuers the ducati functionalization
costs have as the bingo son
just before revolt well there is Islam
Islamist factors that run through almost
every Palestinian and every Arab
political organization it's not I mean
it's not specific I mean we think of it
as specific the Hamas or so having
chrome about recently because the way
the media covers but that's not the case
I mean he's a hero to Palestinians who
why not even religious not because not
because he was religiously because he
was this the history it was designed
other questions
have you seen that sort of trend or
just how
conceptualize
I have seen a shift and its really
interesting and it's a great question
and I'm going to try to answer that by
going to a special collection called
contests and if I if I have that up here
okay let me let me answer that question
in this man I mean let me go let me let
me do that and instead of to my question
let's go to blue star p oh okay blue
star PR is the premier American base
israel advocacy poster punish you if you
want to get posters that manifest
solidarity with Israel okay then you go
to boost appeal and they can download
these you can buy them and this is this
take a look at the iconography of this
you know Ray Charles is in their native
americans there's some really weird
stuff I mean I totally don't get this
close to at all
and this was considered this was
considered by great Israel solidarity
posted if you can explain that to the
eye but it's on their website and you
know they they have it you can buy it so
so you can go in here you get a very you
know very specific you get a very
specific line of imagery here's another
one went busto which was I thought was
pretty interesting and I've read it
until i read the end which which is
actually interesting and this is a kind
of opposite so it's in it it's a
pro-israeli posted publisher boost up
the out featuring the arab film director
and if you go to what say you read the
entire paragraph that this was taken
from as a whole different context gets
established but i thought it was an
interesting i thought it was an
interesting um effort and bringing this
up as a way to answer your question that
solidarity is to kind of solidarity
solidarity palestine solidarity
southern Israel contains now even
contemporary images and text from
israeli-palestinian focal distance which
is something that yet you know so before
I mean that might be a good thing would
be a bad thing I don't know I try not to
I try not to I try to have any answers I
try just to generate questions so let's
look at some of the later let's look at
some of the latest international
solidarity work
here tonight
here are some of them let's go here this
is probably if there's one place that
you were going to go to look at post is
in international go to places you have
to go to post pub which is preeminent in
terms of both talent these are these are
the artists of post spot who created all
the great Che Guevara and Fidel Castro
and heroic romantic Africa Asia Latin
American political iphoneography and
this is part of the John this is part of
the special collection i think there's
20 and year old together including this
one which is considered to me more or
less a flagship poster of palestine
solidarity
designed by Enrique Raphael Enrique who
was the foremost talent for most Cuban
poster artist bios volumes trained in
America he went to America under the
regime of Batista he went to the new
chef it was new school here in New York
and a couple of other fine educational
institutions learn design and was sent
back to Cuba to desert with the
intention that he was going to design
posters for the casino trade he no
sooner landed that the revolution
happened he took all the skills and he
turned them over to the revolution and
created I want to consider to be some of
the finest example of every would
contemporary a revolutionary postal and
this is based on I don't have it in here
but this is based on a shake I you can
go to the liberation graphics website I
have compared this is based on a postman
called chain time is supposed to call
chain by the same artist so again the
leading Cuban the most famous most
celebrated Cuban poster artist producing
posters in solidarity Palestine carry
that over the board to all the countries
of Western Europe mostly countries of
Africa Asia Latin America and it gives
you a sense of the
of the the pedigree the caliber of
bullet posts are being done on house
nine tonight any last questions
then I was like have a little time so
that people can come up and ask you
questions they may have but the only
thing is that you can consult these
posters in the privacy of your sanity
black you could return and etc but this
is a fantastic resources which we've
always seemed a very small beginning
portion of and again the whole thing is
not only on dance site that's also on
phone with Columbia de senator Palestine
studies site and and this is the person
you can interact with you have questions
if you want to pursue topics you I
pursue he's got the information and he
can put you on the trail of posters if
I'd be relevant and I think you can see
that there are posters in two other very
recent questions about how posters made
the depicting certain kind of new
movements they're just virgins let me
try to compete let me close by coming
back to your question about
for me I've been at this for 30 years
and you know it's always been a post is
dribbling in or trying to get them or do
swaps across the book analogy with the
internet it's like completely different
and here's an example that seemed like
the finest would be and be here cause
that poster project right guys special
collection I'm going to go to Michael
Thompson and here's a guy who literally
does Palestine co he reads the newspaper
and he goes into a studio and does the
past I post so let me and it sends it to
me Mike a little Michael Thompson okay
and he's got his own website I don't put
everything up here because I don't want
you know I don't want people coming to
my site but only see his but you know
this one here the you know the mavi
marmara he did this like within 24 hours
of the boat being attacked this was up
and printable and downloadable as a PDF
and so I mean they turn around time now
for poster production which used to be
weeks or months of whatever now down for
hours even minutes but and
you know that no Palestinian no
Palestinian steh to shun nobody told
this guy to do it nobody paid him to do
it you know he just read the newspaper
when it's a studio in Korean post and
it's this probably 50 50 artists here in
the United States and do the same visit
guy on BBC you think I'm sorry goodnight
oh Willy a real to me I'm not sure I
really uh if you have that link I'd love
to have that time so example of how feed
us stranded 65 and maybe one of them is
about Palestine deandrea 64 by the park
I could actually put all three in a 65
of them because this there is one of the
house any other questions join me in
thanking thank you
you